all right
um hi everyone welcome to the ddps
seminar uh before we introduce our
invited speaker let's go over some
rules and resist logistics first of all
please mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you are welcome to admit and
ask
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them in qna session at the end
second today's tdp seminar is open to
external audiences therefore
no classified discussion is allowed so
please watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our youtube channel
that's about it
uh now let me introduce our speaker
today it is an honor to host steve sun
who is an associate professor at
columbia university since
2014 he obtained his phd from
northwestern in 2011 and worked as a
senior member of technical staff at
sandia national lab
from 2011 and 2013 it was actually
across the street from lawrence
livermore national lab so it was very
close
and his research focuses on theoretical
computational and data-driven mechanics
or multi-phase materials with complex
micro structures he is the recipient of
several awards including the ias
iacm john
agrees a word ice
gnqa
with a medal uh prize and the asce
emi and da vince awards the nsf career
award young investigator award from the
army research office and air force
office of scientific research
okay today steve will talk about
data-driven constitutive uh updates from
model-free pro-elasticity to levels of
plasticity trained by neural networks
which is very interesting topic so
please enjoy and expect a wonderful talk
now without further ado let me pass the
button to steve by asking one random
question as usual today's random
question is
what is your favorite things to do other
than research
uh
yeah i would say spend time with
our my children
students
my children are you as well
my student is also my academic children
but
if i have time i will spend
time with my biological tutors
how many do you have
i have two so you have two okay so you
have a plane all right the stage is
yours thank you steve
okay so yeah so so uh yanzo thank you
very much for the
introductions and the invitations to
give the talk
i bring back my memory uh the time i
leave livermore uh lots of wonderful
memory um so today i would like to talk
about
um
i would like to talk about our recent
work related to
using machine learning or data-driven
techniques
to create a constitutive response for
computer simulations in particular for
porous media and for solid
that actually
have a path dependence uh
constituted response
okay so before i get into the details i
will let you first give
the credit to the
to the hero who actually
done the majority of their work and all
of the implementations are
nicholas awareness my former student and
my current postdoc that worked on the
level set pacificity and
bahadur
bamini's that are actually working on
the model v pro mechanics so
uh roughly speaking i will talk about
the model 3 pro mechanics in the first
half of the talk and i will talk about
the level set positivity
so before i get into the details i would
like to talk a little bit about the
history of
of the
um
rather unconventional way to write
constituted law which is something that
uh which is actually related to the
to the ai and machine learning
um
so we did a literature review i i think
that uh we can actually at least chase
back the first new network
constitutional to the in the 1988
um
where we we know that
there is a
attempt on training new network uh to
create a constituted law for congress by
that time there are not yet any
recurring new network yet so the
approach is to include a multiple
previous time step and then using it to
actually represent a path dependent
behavior
then there are more work related to the
deal with the various uh improvement on
the new network concentrated model
but um in 2016 actually the first offer
is in the audience
then there is also another approach on
introducing model-free approach um
that enable a computer simulation to be
done with our constitutional law
uh and then there are many many other
work that are actually related also to
the
so-called deep data revolutions and then
um
so um
i guess a little bit of personal history
i think that when i was um
a phd student or postdoc we are still
not yet in the ai spring so-called so i
also
tried to write the type of the data
resolutions and i learned i graduated in
2011 so a little bit before that and so
um
so the the talk i'm going to talk about
in a sense is the summary of my own
perspective on
or or based on my own experience on work
working uh
in trying to cons using the machine
learning ai technique to generate a
constitutive law
uh so i will first
talk a little bit about the different
approach uh maybe a little bit of survey
on the difficult
on the various approach that uh we can
find in the literature and then
one thing that we actually
want to achieve in using the ai and
machine learning degree constituted law
is that we want something very easy to
interpret but we also want something
that work well with the limit data
so in a sense we can uh in the
literature we can find neural network
that are only used or material
parameter identifications in this sense
the model will be very easy to interpret
because
with the algorithm and with the theory
is really easy to interpret
a given constituted model but then the
problem is that it lacked the ability to
discover new mechanism
um and then
uh and then there are symbolic
regressions and recurrent neural network
that actually have different attributes
symbolic regression for example can
actually
allow us to create a mathematical
equation based on the data but it's
really hard to use in high dimension
simply because the parametric space is
so so large there's so many ways to
write equations
and then there are recurrent neural
networks that are actually hard to
interpret the results at least not
directly
and then there are model free approach
that doesn't have a model at all but it
requires a large amount of the data
so how do we get there is something that
i initially think about so how do we
actually write a model that does doesn't
require a large amount of data and yet
being
able to capture the physics
but then there are another thing that
are important to consider and that is
when we have a very complicated physical
phenomena and then it's really hard to
um
a write a model so when we train a
constituted law uh it involves a large
amount of computational power um
um maybe produce a lot of greenhouse gas
along the way but uh but also uh
training uh conservative law or creating
a constituted law is not easy
um in in this case uh
in a recurring neural network for
example we need to
in additional to formulating the problem
we also need to tune the hyper parameter
on the other hand the model 3 approach
has a great advantage in the sense that
uh if we have enough data so we we don't
actually need to spend any time on
creating a model uh we just need to
actually create a mechanism to search
uh for the material data and so there's
no uh we and we so what in this talk
what we actually want to focus on
is actually uh two situations
the one situation is that uh we have um
we have enough data
and then in this case we can actually
adequately using uh um
a model-free approach to actually
complete the computer simulations
or when we actually have a model or we
actually gathering the data in which
case a deterministic model are actually
insufficient or or or very difficult to
capture the physics um this is actually
commonly encountered in uh
for example in hydraulic simulations
where the permeability
velocity relationship has very high in
variance in which case uh the pawn of
writing a deterministic model that
capture the mean behavior
uh is less meaningful
because you simply cannot matching the
experimental observations
another case that we want we need to
deal with is that
in general
unlike the other field where the big
data
assumptions
is actually can be taken for granted
experimental data for solid or for
hydraulic data are usually expensive
so when the data is actually limited the
the model-free approach because of the
lack of the model
may not actually functions as good as we
would hope to be in this case
uh we want to switch to a machine
learning model that actually allow us to
predict the future events without a loss
of data
without demanding a lot of data
and then what we actually also want to
explore is the interface between the two
when is it possible that we can mix this
uh
uh these two strategy to create the best
computer simulations depends on what
data we can get
and this is actually the
a problem that we constantly think in
our research group
so roughly speaking the model uh the
machine learning model are done by my
postdoc nicholas awareness and then the
model 3 approach are actually done by
bahadur who's in the audience
so uh
here we basically extend the
the idea that a previous uh
um
from a influential paper from the
uh from the um
from the caltech group
uh we're basically trying to solve the
we have a computer um
uh simulations that are governed by the
balance principle
uh for the pause pole mechanics problem
we have the balance of linear momentum
and we have a balance of mass that are
actually function as the physical
constraint
okay so in these
two
problem there are two constituted law
that are actually um
that will actually require experimental
data to complete the model one is
actually the relationship between the
string
and the effective stress
another one is actually the relationship
between the pressure gradient
and the diastasis velocity
so if you look at the data pair we
actually have a string
pair and then we have a passive gradient
and velocity pair
and in a typical way uh when we actually
want to uh create a pole
elasticity model we would actually
conduct tests to obtain the stress
string relationships with under
different pole pressure and we would
actually try to conduct hydraulic tests
to obtain the
uh the relationship between passive
gradient and velocity
now here
one thing to notice uh what to notice is
that in general the solar mechanics and
the
hydraulic data have different uh level
of uh variants
you can see that for example in this uh
digital work physics paper and that
published in 2013 the bug modulus uh
discrepancy are actually
within 10 to 20 order but the hydraulic
uh
constituted response are actually within
one order in the in the log scale
so um
so the data in uh inherently have
different amount of
variance or noise
and uh and so the the treatment uh to
have to combine these two constituted
law together is actually not actually
task in particular in the model-free
approach
so uh here we did not actually need
anything new compared to the classical
model fee approach uh the only
difference
is that we actually add uh additional
concentrated law and a new company
equations
so long story short the idea is that uh
we would actually have a solution space
that are actually uh
sorry sorry about
the moving of the slide so we would
actually have a
constant we will actually have a
metaphor
that actually uh um uh collect all the
admissible solutions from the physical
constraint and we actually also have a
material manifold that are coming from
the data
the key point unlike the classical
problem is actually not to create a
smooth
uh constitutive law that actually allow
us to put the two model together to
yield a unique solutions but we want to
actually find out what is the closest
pawn in the material database that
actually minimize the distance of the
physical constraint so in this case this
would involve uh
optimizations that are both continuous
in the sense we want to actually
find out the way to minimizing the the
distance from the manifold of the
physical constraint but we also need to
select the particular material pawn in
the database that allow us to minimize
the discrepancy
so the extensions of the
pause media problem uh is actually um
is not a
particular difficult um what we actually
need to do is actually to minimize the
discrepancy between the
um the the material pawn data and also
the constitutive uh
uh and also the constituted law so here
the important thing that we need to
invest here our invent here however is
the notions of the distance
and this we will talk about it later
later on
but long story short um in the single uh
combination in the single physics case
what we actually want to introduce is
actually a norm for a
product norm for the string and stress
and the stress space we want to
introduce the notion so that we can
measure how close the stress strength uh
uh uh data from the material data are
actually to uh
uh from the from the from the pawn of
the
of the constituted manifold
okay so here
the idea is you use the product norm in
the sense that um
we would define a vector space uh we
will consider the coefficients of the we
will consider the component of the
string and stress
as a six dimensional component so
together the stress string would have 12
um would have would constitute a
12 dimension vector space and equipped
with a norm that actually resembles any
genome so uh s
and c are actually um
c uh so as here the s tensor here is
actually the inverse of the c tensor so
in this case this provide us a measure
of the distance
between the um the constitutive data and
we can
expand that idea into the
uh pole mechanics data as well so in the
in the case of the multi-physics we
would actually solve the minimization
problem for the solid
and also for the or for the fullest um
but then the questions that uh we need
to ask is that um
how do we define this c and then the s c
and also these are two norms
okay so
you can see that the string and stress
are actually of different order uh they
have different units so it makes sense
to actually re-scaling them uh to make
the notion of the
distance actually um
uh more clear
but then the thing is that the the
constituted response are not necessarily
linear
so if we actually introduce
a product norm to actually measure the
distance is it the best way so this is
something that we are currently
investigating
sorry i think some problem with the
okay
so the problem um the
optimization problem uh including
two-step
and the interesting thing is that one of
them is actually continuous we want to
actually fix the uh material data
uh pawn that we idealize and we actually
want to find the physical fields such
that it minimize the discrepancy
of the data and and the physics field
and then
and then this could be a
differentiable optimizations because the
residual are actually um
uh
a smooth but on the other hand we also
have a local step
this is actually uh in a sense uh
um the replacement of the constituted
law we actually want to i identify the
material pawn that actually on the
database that are actually minimizing
the distance
in so the
in this approach in the modal v approach
the
most difficult part
or the one of the most major challenge
is to solve the descript optimization
problem where we don't rely on the
gradient but rely on the search and
ranking to determine which pawn is
actually
the best well fit uh the optimum pawn to
actually fulfill the
closest to the physical constraint
okay so the continuous problem are
actually uh the metaphor are simply uh
the specific uh um
a quantitative response that fulfill the
the balance equations
for the linear momentum and the
and the mass
so in this case we can actually
introduce a lagrangian we can use the
lagrangian multiplier approach to
enforce the particular data set uh
uh
to to actually formulate the
optimization problem this is actually
very similar to the original data
different paper the only thing that we
knew we add again is the new additional
equation for the balance of linear
momentum and then the introduction of
the time
so but then the thing that we want to
address is the following as we see
earlier
we have data of different variants
and we actually also
the data also have a discrepancy in the
sense that obtaining
in general obtaining the hydraulic data
could be more expensive
than obtaining a stress strain curve so
how do we address this discrepancy of
the data availability issues and the way
we propose is use a hybridized approach
uh the idea is actually again very
simple we don't actually
need to use the
uh the the data driven approach for both
constituted law we can actually choose
one of them and in this case we can
actually minimize we can actually
simplify the search problem
if you have enough data on a particular
constituted law or if the constituted
law are too hard to generate then we
actually switch from a model based
approach to a model 3 approach
if we actually if the motor base
approach is actually suitable then we
will simply
use the modal base approach this is
actually two additional of this variance
formulations of the hybrid
hybridized or pole mechanics
formulations
in one case the solid model is actually
based on the constituted law
uh but then the full
model is based on the data on the other
case the reverse is actually true
so this is actually the just
comparisons um of the two approach
obviously a model based approach if it's
actually calibrated correctly would
demand less data and not only that it
can also save time uh in this case in
the brief force approach if you look at
the hybridized uh approach in both
hybridized approach it's actually
a function faster
when we have uh whenever we have more
data point
um
so so this hybridized approach in that
sense could actually help us save some
time
but another important issues we want to
deal with is the descript optimization
search so we don't have a model but the
price replaced is that in the database
we need to identify the the optimum data
point that help us fulfill the physical
constraint
uh and this is actually classically done
by the nearest neighborhood search but
here we'll try to do something
differently um
so first we will try to our approach is
to try to use the kdg search
and uh we basically do a simple check
here if you actually have the if you
have this um
product norm that looks like an energy
norm okay so c can actually split into
two parts
uh based on the uh chelsea
factorizations
and in this case we can actually rewrite
the material space in uh
you and then we can minimizing it using
the l2 norm instead of using an energy
norm after the factorizations we
basically will store the data using the
the factorized uh uh
material database
and we can use the and we can use the
kdg search to speed up the search
so you can think about it if you have
the brute force way uh to search the
data point what we basically have is
that we have uh we basically need to
measure the distance between the
um
the manifold the uh the physical
constraint metaphor to the particular
material pawn and we actually need to
minimizing the distance and then rank
them
so in the kdc search we can save a lot
of time by identified by pre-petitioning
the domain and then find out the and
then use the partitions to actually
saving the search time to identify the
pawn
sorry about it
so one thing that we actually did is
that we partitioned the data space
into subspace and then using the kdc
search to identify the particular
partitions of the data and then in the
last level
we would actually just use the needles
label research to identify the material
of the particular material data
uh so the result is actually
uh the benefit is quite obvious so we
try to do the classical
of brute force research and in in this
case when we increase the number of data
we actually the model fee
accuracy is increasing but then the time
is actually the search time also
increased because now we have to compare
more pawn
versus in the kdc search because in each
time of the partitions we actually would
only
uh um select half of the data pawn we
can actually uh
have uh the the surf speed for the
discrete problem i actually increased
much slower
in a much slower way so that could
actually help us to obtain the
to continue the computer simulations uh
even when we have a lot of data pawn to
compare
uh this is actually more uh comparisons
uh for the for another problem as you
can see out the more it doesn't the
whether you use the kdg search or the
root force approach is is actually
uh doesn't matter much when we don't
have enough data point but when the data
pawn are actually increasing then the
then the speed uh become our important
uh issues and the kdc search can
impossibly
help us uh continue the model fee
simulation without uh suffering from a
very slow uh consultative update
so we compare first with the linear
problem which obviously doesn't require
a model-free approach this is just to
check the model is correct whether we
use the model free or using a fully data
defense when we are given enough data
pawn
uh this is actually the details of the
uh console td response predictions as
you can see
one thing we can observe is that when we
don't have enough data pawn um the
constituted response that are actually
obtained turn to
uh tend to lack smoothness over time
this is actually simply because of the
fact that when the database actually
when when the pawn crowd in the
constitutive
manifold are more spa then the the
choice of the data we have is actually
less and hence you can see that
artificial oscillations which supposedly
can be resolved by adding more data pawn
uh so so this is actually in a in a
sense illustrate the fact that and this
by the way is just a 1d problem so it
illustrate the fact that the model 3
approach could work but then um
when we don't have enough data then uh
then the then the
we need i also need to you need to deal
with the fact that some of the con the
lack of the data would actually lead to
a
model respond that are less moved than
expected
uh this is actually another comparisons
in the stress relaxations
so our goal is to simulate a pulse media
so a pause media when compressed
even though the solid respawn have no
path dependent behavior because of the
diffusions of the prophylact it will
lead to a stress relaxation
so here we first again generate a linear
database where we simply compare
and check the correctness of the
implementations and then we actually
compare
uh the the algorithm we check the
algorithm rather it functions on the
non-linear um
model so in this case we use the file
element as the benchmark and we generate
the data from a model to create a point
cloud and then we actually examine
the concentrated response
as you can see here when the data when
sufficient data are available
um the model can converge correctly
uh this is actually uh another
simulation for the model 3 approach in
which case we use a real um data
of the of a sandstone data
so as you can see here the porosity
permeability relationships are actually
in a prawn crowd that are naturally not
uh that will be very high in variance in
which case we can actually use the
kossini common to get the meat behavior
but the meat behavior doesn't
necessarily capture the physics or even
the training of the constituted law
for that reason
it actually makes sense to try the model
3 approach where we simply map the
concentrated pawn into the available
data point
and this is actually a fully coupled
problem where we apply the displacement
with no flux boundary and we see how the
pole pressure build up and how does the
water moving inside the domain
in this case we use a hybridized
formulations in the sense that the soil
mechanics are actually coming from a
model only the hydraulic part are
actually coming from the using the data
different approach the reason is that
the solid concentrity response we can
get a reasonable
stress ring curve that doesn't have the
high invariance with reasonable accuracy
uh i mean particular um
from the classical triaxial compaction
test data
so um and this is actually the response
we will get the domain are actually uh
heterogeneous with uh porosity
fluctuated in the space and we can
actually run the calculates the long the
calculations and compute the co-passer
so if you look at one particular
constitution
one quadrature pawn in the
in the domain
what you will see here is actually that
the the data as we actually run the
selection it choosing different data
points on the material data on the
material database instead of trying to
uh is that from trying to make a
predictions inside a smooth predictions
so this
could make sense when we actually could
not write um
a good constituted law that actually
able to capture all the pawn or in this
case deal with the high intelligence
you can see the analogues this is
actually very close to a case where the
data in a new network training where the
wear is all very overfeeding in a sense
we will probably get a very similar
behavior
so uh there are some ongoing work uh
actually my
student told me not to
not to show all the steps so i'll just
show the results um
but here is actually the idea
if you think about it the material
constituted response is not linear so
the tools to using uh
to to assuming that the data is actually
in the equilibrium record space is not
necessarily the best approach
uh the reason is the notion of distance
so if you think about it if you want to
model the distance be on a flat surface
it makes sense to use the norm to give
us a sense of distance but if you
actually try to measure the distance of
on earth like the distance between paris
to japan
um the data itself of the surface is not
a flat line so the notion of distance
using the norm as a replacement of the
distance doesn't apply so we need to
think about uh a different way to
actually minimizing the distance
by thinking about where
what is the metaphor of the of the data
that they live in
so here uh without all the details but i
hope that we will finish the paper by
december this is one numerical
experiment in which case we have a
database but then we actually taking out
some data
okay and then um
the the upper result is actually the
metaphor
calculations we use we construct a
constitutive metaphor and then using the
the correspond at the right matrix to
actually measure the distance and then
solve the same model-free problem
you can see that even in this case where
there's a big hole in the database we
can get a response a good result versus
the classical um
a distance search will actually lead to
oscillations in the string field uh this
is also another uh ongoing work is to
deal with the model fee problem when we
don't have enough data
again uh you can compare um
the two approach
in this particular case we simply try to
shear uh we try to apply the
constitutive law in uh on the trust
system one interesting thing we find is
that when we don't have uh
uh in this particular case if you don't
have enough data the even though the
material is completely elastic it's
non-linear elastic we may actually
create a
seemingly path-dependent behavior just
because of the
due to the artifact uh uh um
due to the artificial effect of the
search and also the lack of the data
bond but when we actually um
consider the metaphor approach we may
actually get a smooth respawn
so here the the key thing we
we try to convey is that we will try to
think about
uh
the right approach uh when we deal with
different amount of the data how do we
switch the strategy and also how do we
measure so one thing that um
in this research we find in particular
exciting is is not just given the amount
of the data how do we generate the model
but how do we properly measure uh the
the notion of distance
so uh and then this will go to the
i think i'm a little bit running out of
time so maybe i would
uh how many times should i
you're okay uh we have a 10 let's let me
know if i'm actually running out time
yeah yeah so
so the
another strategy we want to talk about
is uh working for basicity
so at this point we haven't
we know that some literature that
dealing with um
model-free uh possibility
but um
i think that right now um
for the positive data because the
behavior is path dependent we want to go
back to something that uh that are more
model based just to
uh uh overcoming the demands of the data
so uh here we were actually for the
positivity we were actually using um a
new network's uh strategy
so i want to talk a little bit about the
history of the constituted law hand
crafting a constitutive law as we all
know is a very time consuming process
you can see in this figure
it takes almost 100 years from
what mises j2 plasticity
into a sand model but then how many 100
years do we need to wait when we have a
when we have so many new material that
getting design or metal material that
are getting designed
so there is a demand on try to
automate this process in some sense and
try to
take advantage of the model also to
to improve the data collection process
um so
the classical approach
by classic i mean a few years ago that
getting started is to use the recurrent
neural network to generate a
constitutive model for the path
dependent behavior
but then there is a problem in this
approach in the sense that
when we actually use the strength
history to predict the stress
uh it's really difficult to
access the
um
the thermodynamics or the admissibility
of the constituted law for example
without the speed of the elastic and
plastic string is up to analyzing what
energy getting stored what is the energy
dissipations
so we use alternative way where we would
actually cut the whole learning process
into two steps
the training of the elastic energy
functional and the chaining of the
u-surface in particular the training of
elastic energy functional have been
talked about in the literature quite
often but here our focus would be on how
to train the the new surface
okay so in particular
if we actually just simply trying to
parametric find out the optimum
parameter of the use surface we won't be
able to discover anything new
so how do we actually retain the general
fee uh how do you make the learning
problem as general as possible and not
making it too difficult that is actually
one of our goal in this research
uh so for the lack of time i probably
would go over this a little bit faster
so
the elastic part we can actually
generate energy functional by actually
the constitutive law by training the
energy functional
so here the idea is that instead of
training
generating a supervised learning that
link the strength to the stress we try
to create a more label by actually uh
using both the energy the strength uh
sorry the energy the stress and the
stiffness all as the output
and we actually have this data in the
experiment we're just not using it
in the classical machine learning
training
the advantage of including the stiffness
and the energy is that when we increase
the energy we can check the physical
property of the energy
for example we can enforce complexity
and the good thing about study in
incorporated stiffness is that it is
similar we can also check
the
ellipticity and then the stability of
the energy functional
uh so this is actually some of the
response that we can get in the training
of elastic energies functional we
actually found out that uh using a high
order objective functions actually held
not only on generating a better
steepness but also on generating better
stress and energy even though the
minimizations include a free term
instead of just the energy term
and this
uh
method have not only applied on our
direct remarkable summations for the
final element it has also been applied
in our recent work on simulating uh hmx
crystal uh injecting material uh for
finite strength problem
in this case we actually doesn't have
the
energy data the hybrid elastic energy
data but we actually have a stress data
and then we use the initial point of the
energy to change the concentrated law
for this poly crystal we can see that um
even with a without a very sophisticated
multi-layer perceptron we can actually
create a very good
uh match in the concentric response on
the stress string curve
but more importantly is that
we can also introduce uh the physics
through our transfer learning strategy
so here we basically uh try to enforce
two things the material frame in
difference and then the symmetry
we actually introduced a test where the
rotation tensor are put into the
deformation gradient and we actually
check whether we can get the same energy
when we change the observer orientations
and we also check whether for the
symmetry rotations rather we can
maintain the same concentrated response
um
and another thing that we can also do is
to check the acoustic cancer behavior so
when we compute the tangents we
for a given orientation and
we we obtain acoustic tensor and then
the eigenvalue of the acoustic cancer
gives us the wave speed of the material
in this particular case we can actually
find out what is the minimum um
of the
wave speed and we can actually ensure
that the constituted law actually lead
to a stable result by ensuring that the
wave speed is actually not going
negative
uh
i think for the second time we don't
have time to
go through that but i also want to
saying that the tuning of the hyper
parameter we also make a attempt on
training it
uh with the reinforcement learning and
we can find the optimum set of the data
so uh
and also
for the level set training approach that
we introduced one of the important
important thing is that it demands the
degree of continuity
so in
but then the
while we can actually choose the hybrid
tangents
activation function to enable that i've
what we actually found out at least in
critically is that um
using the ielu
uh seems to be a good choice if we can
actually introduce additional multiple
layer to increase the degree of
continuity so the idea is very simple uh
we have uh
ielu
activation functions
you see that corner here if you take the
derivative you'll get a jump so it
doesn't have enough continuity for us to
take the second derivative to obtain the
tangent
however we can introduce a multiple
layer so that the layer add itself times
itself together and that would actually
increase the defensive ability uh
and then we can actually control the
degree of our differential uh the
continuity
uh such that we can actually obtain a
smooth tangent
so this is just some small trick
uh and in that particular case uh this
technique is a pie on identifying the u
surface uh permission signing the u
surface
so you can think about that um the most
chewy way to call to channel to generate
a constituted law is to create a
learning problem where we actually have
a string history to particular stress
however if we actually incorporate the
positive framework what we actually
want to do is that
what if if we know the elasticity the
positivity constituted law could be
complete if we know how the use surface
involved
in the stress space
with that uh with that assumptions then
we can actually consider the
constitutive law motoring problem as a
geometry problem we simply want to
evolve a level set in the parametric
space in this case uh for isotropic
material that would be just the
principal stress
so
with the direct numerical simulations we
can actually run simulations that are
purely elastic and then compared with
the dns that activate the plastic
positivity portions and from that we can
actually obtain the data that
that identifies the plastic string and
from that we can constitute a new
surface
so there appears work on using the
nerves to identify the use surface for
perfect plasticity the problem is that
when material show a plastic behavior
the use surface can be evolved in any
opportunity way possible
if we actually from a solid mechanics
background if you unders uh if you study
j2 percentage we all know that the new
service can enlarge in the stress space
or move
in the stress space but in general uh
the material of the the symmetry of the
used stress can also change it can also
rotate
so one of the most generalized way to
represent that stress string behavior is
actually uh create a
parameterization of the new surface
along with the cumulative plastic string
so in this case we were formulating the
u-surface revolutions as uh as a as a
hamilton jacobi equations you can think
about this very similar to training a
pin problem where we actually uh try to
solve that uh hamilton jacobi problem
with the with the u surface
corresponding to the principle stress
and the accumulated plastic string
the only difference here is that
we only need to train the
the this pin problem once and this could
be it and then the result would be a
constituted law that can be reused many
many times as a replacement of the
classical return constituted law
uh so i think i'm about running out of
time so i would just talk about the
basic idea um we can get a in this
particular case we can in this
particular paper we can actually obtain
the u surface and then use it and then
if we continue to load the material we
can observe what is the plastic string
and from that we can actually record the
involvement
and then substitute and then adding the
data and then the physical cons
and the physics and the gathering law of
the hampton jacobi equations we can
actually change
we can all and we can actually change uh
uh use surface that are actually getting
evolved with the activity plastic string
or the any internal variable
so here to simplify the training again
we want to leverage the we want to
generate the constituted law that are as
moved as possible uh to overcome the
oscillation we may sometimes observe in
the recurrent neural network
so the way to do it is the following
when we generating the data we would
only
observe the yielding pawn
uh but then this will be just a pawn in
the it will be just be a surface in the
parametric space however we can make
assumptions that the u surface is a
scientist functions in this case then we
will generate a lot we can generate
as many data as we want in the principal
stress space in addition to the hamilton
jacobi equation to change the model
so in this particular case uh with the
assumption that the u front surface is
also a scientist and functions we can
actually the experimental data can help
us capture how does the u surface
involve uh in time uh
and then and then the the resultant
constantly the law are actually
in this particular case can be put into
a classical return mapping algorithm
we can also use the plastic string
increment to introduce associative flow
view as this example show we we don't
necessarily need to change a plastic
potential we can but we can also compare
the rotations between the uh
the stress gradient and the parasito
direction to generate a non-associative
route
uh this is actually the difference
between simply training a new surface
and assuming then the u surface is
actually a scientific functions and the
implementations is actually very simple
this is also one of the attractive form
of the level set plasticity model in the
sense that
if you have a production code or
constituted law that already have a
return mapping in the string space you
simply need to replace the classical uh
elastic energy functional and then the
yield functions with the chain functions
the elastic
neural network training uh the the new
network that predicts the stress respond
and then the new network
that actually solved the hamilton jacobi
problem will be put in here and here
respectively
and it can actually reproduce a lot of
different plasticity model with
various type of
southerning
this is actually exciting because
instead of hand crafting different type
of concentrated model each time we can
merge all the effort into the into one
meta model and given different data it
can manifest different type of hardening
different type of new servers that uh
that in the history of time i actually
handcraft one by one and it's uh in a
very time consuming manner so this is
some response that actually we see uh we
actually
uh identified uh something very close to
um
to a camcait positive but it can
actually have a very complicated
hardening or softening mechanism in
different uh
loading path
so we can compare this with the rnn even
with the limit data because in this case
we don't need to use the
uh the the um the recurrent neural
network what we actually need to do is
to use the um
uh the multi-layer perception the
training is much easier and because
we don't actually need we would actually
impose a memory through a kkd conditions
rather than through the memory gate we
don't see the oscillation that could be
occurred in lstm or indicated recurrent
neural network
this is more response as you can see the
the nice thing is not only we get a more
stable response but you can clearly see
that we increase the interval ability of
the concentrated law here we know how
does the new surface evolve and that
tells us something about the anaesthetic
involvement of the youth surface and
also we can check whether the yield
surfaces are thermodynamically
admissible by check simply checking
whether it's actually have the capacity
required
for a stable or physical
compatible model
so uh we're using this uh to replace the
classical fe square approach in this
case fft final element approach in which
we have a poly crystal and then we train
it with the new network and then we
replacing it with the fe square approach
as you can see we can actually run the
polycrystal stimulation without actually
associating each gaseous pump with
expensive fft simulations and not only
that we can discover a microscopic model
that actually have interesting physics
in it
so this is the comparisons between the
two fft simulations with the circuit
model as you can see the results are
recently closed
we also think about how to expand this
research in particular what we haven't
talked about is the way to incorporate
the internal variable
internal variable represent
representation of the memory
and one of the reason that the material
demonstrate path dependent behavior is
because of the memory effect due to the
particle internal rearrangement change
and this could be very effectively
represent in a graph the microstructure
can be represented by a graph
and there could be a way to capture how
does the graph evolving in the during
the constituted law during the past uh
positivity loading and we can actually
connected with the physics
so um
uh in this case instead of use
handcrafting your fiber cancer or
porosity
or whatever um
a physical internal wearable to
constitute a positive a constituted law
we will directly generate a low
dimensional representation of the graph
uh and then using it using the
revolutions of the input feature vector
uh to actually uh uh incorporate into
the constituted law uh respawn um uh in
so we can see some comparison this one
is still ongoing work and this is first
benchmark against a recurrent neural
network um but you can see that it can
be predict pretty complicated uh
cyclic behavior
another thing that we have uh been doing
is to introduce the variational
plasticity in energy with energetic
approach where we actually simply change
the elastic energy functional and then
the plastic energy functional
uh and this is actually compared again
the j2 um positive
case and also finally one ongoing work
is not only on the upscaling of the
constituted law but on the dam scaling
so if we actually have fe square
simulations at some point um we want to
actually continue the simulation not
using the new network but directly
uh converge it back into the
microstructure can we do that so in this
particular case the final elements uh
notes are actually represent as a graph
and we actually
found out what is a low dimensional
feature of of the of the nokway graph
evolved and then we're using that uh
look wave to action we actually using
the low dimensional representations of
the enco feature vector
we predict the revolution of the input
feature vector and then using a decoctor
to get back the field data
uh so with that i think i already said
too much running out of time so i will
say the following um
we have uh in the constitutive law
problem we more or less deal with
different amount of the data what we can
control is a string and a hyper
parameter and then the method but one
thing i think that uh
at least based on my personal experience
that are very important is not
necessarily
finding what is the most uh latest
gadgets for the new network uh that
architecture that can solve the problem
but to think about how to formulate the
problem properly uh and i think that in
this case uh i think i show a few
examples where we are giving the same
amount of the data but it depends on how
we use those data to make the
predictions we can get a very diverse
uh
response of different quality and
robustness
so with that i want to um
i want to thank all the audience for
their patience uh to listen to my talk i
want to
friend my sponsor for their continuous
uh support i want to thank my student
again nick and bahadur for um
working very hard on getting this thing
done and uh we can you can find more
information from our research group
webpage uh www.promechanix.org
and thank you
thank you thank you so much steve for
the wonderful talk um i i didn't want to
stop you because um
i i hope i wanted everyone to get um you
know full material from you uh although
it's it's going over time because it's
it's recording people can check um the
recorded video
next time um
so that i i didn't want to stop you all
right great thank you so much for the
great talk i'd like to have a q a
session um
maybe for fall
briefly um
if you have any questions please unmute
yourself and then ask questions
uh have a quick one if that's all right
your talk so the uh the data or the
model free the data driven approach
where you're looking for the closest
point
in your solution space
you showed
the points that were selected by a
single
single gas point in your simulation have
you looked simulation wide at the
statistics to see if you are
giving all points at a given say
porosity even treatment or if you tend
to localize within regions as a solution
space
and so say you know you have some
some statistical variability in your
data set
you tend to
over estimate the variability based on
your sampling or capture uniformly i
mean
are all the points been equally weighted
or are the ones at the surface of a
cloud of points or the internal interior
of the cloud points
tend to be weighted more heavily
for example uh
so right now uh uh
so
if i understand the question correctly
um
right now
the pawn doesn't have a different way so
we treat uh equally but that being said
um
the energy norm
the c and s parameter that you choose in
a sense also affect the indirectly
affecting the importance of how you pc
vp sections of
of a distance
and i think there are some work from the
from the french group lauren steiner
that actually uh study how does the
choice of the sea he's solving his own
mechanics problem how does it affecting
the
the convergence um yeah so to answer the
questions uh
my understanding and my student bahadur
is in audience he can also jump in my
understanding is that the date how does
the data distribute does matter uh here
we in the most example the data is quite
equally distributed uh but then again um
if you actually have a data that
concentrates in some parametric domain
and very small in other domain that
could cause the issues if you're
simulating in the region that have very
small data right because you you even
the closest pawn you can actually map to
is still very far away
from uh from the
from the from the ideal situation where
you have the actual data
so yeah
i don't i guess i don't mean are you
purposefully applying weights to the
data points i mean does the algorithm
tend to
um bias some points more than others
because of whether they're in the middle
or the edge of a cloud that's like if
you
sample the number of times each point
was selected as the nearest point in the
simulation
i don't
i don't think so although strictly
speaking if you're a la nina concert did
you uh respond then because you compel a
sort of layer artificial energy uh from
that energy norm maybe i can show that
energy
thing so big because so you do you would
actually
if your material is actually la nina
and then your your norm is actually your
c is actually constant you do have a
perception that would buy us uh
that would actually buy us two words uh
um at some point over the other but it's
not inherently there uh this is just
because of the norm uh
this is just because of the norm you
choose again if the data obviously is
linear then you then then every pawn is
treated equally
it can think about it so um
you can think about it it's like if you
have a curve and then you want to
measure the distance if you're actually
very far away you can actually use the
curve length to measure the distance or
you can use a straight line so if you
use the norm it's equivalent to use a
straight line so that would affect your
perceptions uh they will set affect your
perception a little bit
so you it could be you can think about
it it's like what is that called um in
the 1d case like a differential one form
where your form is actually just a
constant throw um i don't know but
explain it properly but yeah uh but
yeah and actually chanting may also
yeah
what i'm talking about so
at least when i've tried to do
similar things when you have noisy data
like this is that sometimes the the
minimum distance formulation can
preferentially select outliers
but it also depends on how you're
randomly selecting your original data
set
um
and so one of the questions that i had
actually in your plot of the migration
of the single integration point if you
could go to that slide
which is in the neighborhood of this
where was it it was a little bit farther
down where you showed the actual
migration that he had referred to the
migrations so yeah this one
yeah so one of the things that i noticed
here is that there's kind of a direction
to the migration
and so what i was curious is is this
coming out of
because the sometimes i've noticed that
the data points will kind of equilibrate
a little bit because of your uh
constraint set and so
you depend it depends on your data set
and your initial selections but it's
believable to me that you would migrate
to similar portions of the domain
if everything is well conditioned but i
was curious if this is under like a
linear ramping and so it's kind of
updating boundary conditions and that's
why it's pushing you in a direction or
the algorithm is itself
migrating like this
so
i would say
i think that this question are probably
bahadur are you can you answer that
yeah hi uh actually uh
because here we had like uh
we had like porosity is also a feature
for us
so we have like porosity permeability
sorry porosity pressure gradient and uh
velocity
so uh
and for each procedure we have a
different data set
so
our data set is in a sense has one more
dimension uh
than classical sounds
so based on the porosity we just choose
like uh the closest process
from that data update for for example if
your porosity at this point of
simulation is 0.2
uh first i decide uh
find those closest porosity data sets
and then search inside those
those data sets which in which each one
has like so many data points right
yeah so that's that's that's the
hierarchy we do in the actual simulation
for this particular problem because we
wanted to keep track of the porosity
evolution and our datasets are generated
based on that process
okay
so
and so the question i was asking related
to the fact that you kind of seem to
have there's
there's pretty much a rightward trend in
the data like you kind of have a general
direction and my question is through
yeah that's true because of if uh
professor sun go back to the previous
slide you see orally the domain is like
in the compression mode right yep
so because of that compression
compression we expect uh
yeah
the reduction in the porosity and that's
why
you see that trend
okay my cure my question actually was um
are the boundary conditions sometimes in
a non-linear problem very often will
lamp ramp
certain boundary conditions right
and i was curious if that was
what that was or if that was just merely
the constraints kind of cinching in on
the correct data point
in that migration
so the algorithms find that like it's
we don't like we don't assume how to do
that so
the algorithms find the the
the closest data and just substituting
the equations that's that's why
so over the course of that migration
your boundary conditions are constant
in here if i remember correctly for this
i think i increased the boundary that
that displacement is increasing so the
the lateral compression is fixed but
that view is increasing during the time
okay so that makes sense so basically
what we're seeing what so that was kind
of my internal question is i have seen
migrations of data points under fixed oh
yeah definitely this is this is a
transient problem so i usually i
gradually increase the compression
yeah so because yeah it's a problem x
problem so it has multiple time step um
well
yeah i might my question was mostly
whether it was at a single instant in
time or whether this was over over the
entire simulation from the beginning to
the end yeah
cool
and then um
i did have one other question about your
discretization so when you add time to
your constraint equations
uh which is
uh
well we don't necessarily need the exact
one so in the past when i've done that i
needed to make a specific
uh numerical approximation
to set up that constraint did you guys
have to do that or
was there a different space you were
able to make that constraint in
actually we used the idea so in the
optimization sense we could do uh first
in discreting time and then space or
first in space and then time
so
we what we did is like first in time
because when i make it first in time it
would be easier for the distance
minimization to do the optimization on
the space that's why you see that delta
t in the norm
if professor sun goes back one slide
yeah i think that that id also come from
i mean on
relay work i think that
professor ortiz we are with also with
uh i've done some work on that
equivalence what is that called if yeah
static thing it descriptive in time and
have uh
lagrangian and then find the minimizer
so yeah so if we look at the paper we
basically uh
follow that idea just just for
convenience more than anything
just to make a make it
descript in time uh in each in each
time instant you kind of solving a local
uh cause i static problem and then we
upgrade it to the next step
okay
yeah i just i didn't have could you go
back to the equation just one more step
or i think he said in your slides
oh there it is okay
so yeah you can see here that looks like
actually one more actually one more
previous
i think one is like previous than this
one
and also more go back to this process
more sorry
here you see the next one here you see
that delta t multi multiply the next one
this one
yeah
so
yeah the pro mechanics the pro mechanics
metric is the first equation uh below
than the proposed known for per
elasticity
yeah that delta t is coming because of
the
first discretizing in time yeah yeah
yeah
yeah just to make it consistent because
because that one would have the unit of
a power and this one would have energy
[Music]
right sounds good i think
is there any other question i think it's
a time to wrap up by the way
um
i think we're 15 minutes past wrap up
but that's good i mean that's good
there are many interesting
in the professor's son's work uh
presenting today yeah very interesting
yeah wonderful wonderful all right um i
guess with that we can conclude the
seminar let's thank the our speaker um
the steve son thank you thank you so
much
and
hopefully um um you know this becomes a
tends to uh do the future collaboration
uh with uh yeah i hope so yeah i i may i
may one day receive lawyers
so yeah i mean don't just do the
collaboration with the sandia please
collaborate with uh lawrence livermore
too okay
yeah yeah
all right thank you
okay let's end the uh and the meeting
thank you everyone for joining thank you